see youtubers is Charlie these he's
blowing up right now so potential really
awesome flash movie news that I'll
explain and Flash Batman button
crossover what I'm going to do is I'm
going to start with the flash movie news
and then I'll talk about the flash comic
book stuff with Batman because they just
threw a whole bunch of bombs out there
and you may not have read it so I'll
give a spoiler warning before I get to
the comic book stuff because it was just
released so the big news for the flash
movie is that Robert Zemeckis is rising
to the top of the pile to direct you
probably know that the flash movies been
floundering lately there's been all this
talk about the nightly movies a new
Batgirl movie the Aquaman movies in the
middle of filming right now but there's
been no talk about the flash movie
they've gone through two other directors
already they're already working on
another draft of the script so it's like
when are we going to get our flash movie
so now it seems like the guy that did
the Back to the Future movies which is
what he's most known for is going to be
doing the flash movie but it's not
confirmed he hasn't been hired yet he's
just one of the many directors they're
meeting with it would be a giant slam
dunk if they're able to get him because
not only is a great director but they
just spent a whole bunch of time on this
week's episode of the flash making
references to Back to the Future it's
such an iconic franchise that of course
it shows up everywhere time-travel is a
big component of the Flash character so
of course the person who directed some
of the most iconic time-travel movies of
ever would provide for some really fun
Easter eggs doing a flash movie it's
just like Back to the Future
and what would make me doc Brown you're
going to give you some kind of letter
are you no I will not so it's probably
going to be a while before we find out
about that I would expect by the time we
get to Comic Cons they'll have something
definitive to say but usually when they
sign someone they don't wait to announce
that they just say boom we got our
director we're working on it this is
their tentative release date this is
what's going to happen so I'll totally
do a flash movie update when we get more
information about that but the flash
button issues that everyone's going
crazy about its flash number 21 so it's
a big Batman crossover it mostly takes
place in the Batcave and it's all about
this special DC rebirth button which is
one of the MacGuffin
of the entire series they teased it at
the very beginning last summer in
everyone immediately figured out that it
meant the DC Comics was bringing The
Watchmen characters into the main
continuity and that's kind of what DC
rebirth is meant to do it's meant to fix
their continuity by bringing back all
these old big events so during this
week's issue a whole bunch of really
cool stuff happened with the characters
but one of the big things that it did
was referenced a couple of these really
big temple events in DC's history and
bring them back into continuity so I'll
explain the Easter eggs for that but I
will say careful for spoilers from the
flash number 21 so it actually starts
out with a character called Johnny
Thunder that you may or may not be
familiar with he debuted in the flash
number one he harnesses the power of a
genie from the 5th dimension using this
little pen here that's where the Thunder
is stored so what happened is is that
another character named Chuck team got
that power around the early 2000s which
is funny enough when Jeff Jones was
writing Justice Society so he showed up
during that title and that's about the
time that I started reading Jeff Jones I
actually started reading Justice Society
the minute that he came on to the title
so he became the new version of Johnny
Thunder in like they have the two
different versions of wally west this is
kind of what they're doing with Johnny
Thunder so when he's screaming at the
sky like this crazy old man saying say
you the Thunder where's the Thunder
trying to get it back that's the phrase
that he uses to summon his powers but
they pull him back in a crazy man need
to be quiet we need to up his meds
the main story though is all about the
flash the button in Batman's father from
flashpoint so if you didn't read the
last comic what happens is
is Batman accidentally brings the button
into contact with psycho-pirate helmet
in psycho-pirate is one of those
characters that retains memories from
big universe changing events so like
after crisis on Infinite Earths and
Infinite Crisis big universe altering
things happen in most of the characters
like Superman the flash all the main
characters they don't remember what
happened before time was changed or the
universe was changed or the multiverse
but psycho-pirate does so what happens
is he brings the button into contact
with psycho-pirate helmet and gets a
vision of his father from flashpoint so
he's getting a vision of a different
reality because technically Barry fix
flashpoint so that Thomas Wayne version
of Batman shouldn't exist anymore but
along comes the reverse flash in
tortures Batman beating him up all over
the Batcave before the flash can get
there to help him out but by the time
that he gets there reverse flash
accidentally touches the button is zaps
him away then instantly he travels back
and he's dead and he says he saw the
face of God so as most of you have
probably figured out since that very
first DC rebirth issue the tease at the
end of that is that dr. Manhattan is the
big villain of the series and he somehow
messed with time to cause all these
weird changes that are happening now so
I love all the forensic science that
goes on and this Barry talks about how
that's more important to him than his
ability as a speedster when it comes to
solving crimes in his love for forensic
scientists gives him this bond with
Batman that he doesn't have with the
other Justice League characters he and
Batman are detective bros but what the
flash doesn't tell Batman is that he
detects signatures of his own Speed
Force on the button in the reverse-flash
the radiation that he's talking about is
probably the radiation that dr.
Manhattan gives off himself in when the
reverse-flash saw God he saw dr.
Manhattan who then killed him and sent
him right back but the really big Easter
eggs start to drop when the flash goes
to the Justice League tower in their
Hall of curiosities where they just
store all the weird things that they get
from the crimes that they solve you see
The Phantom Zone projector you see blue
beetles vehicle you see Martian
Manhunter costume I know Martian
Manhunter isn't around right now people
are like he needs to be part of Justice
League he's a core member so you just
look around this room in there
dreg from all over the Justice League's
history going back to the golden age for
adventures that they had so the flash
unfurls the cover from the cosmic
treadmill and says that he's going to
time-travel using it to try and find out
what's going on but he doesn't say
exactly where he's going in Batman's
like you're not going without me in like
when Batman says that he's time travel
before he's talking about Final Crisis
Darkseid hit him with his Omega beams
it's sent him back in time and there was
this big saga of Batman jumping around
in time so you get caveman Batman you
get Batman who's a pirate you get Batman
across all the ages and when they get to
where they're going it turns out to be
Thomas Wayne's Batcave from flashpoint
so flash took them back to flashpoint
which shouldn't exist technically but as
they're traveling you see all these
different realities sort of collapsing
on themselves it's three different eras
of the Justice League showing you three
different versions of the origin story
so what the comic book is doing just
like it's bringing Johnny Thunder back
from the Golden Age is it's making all
these things part of the continuity - so
I believe this is the Silver Age version
of the origin story from Justice League
number one there's Jael a year one which
was mark Wade's 90s version of the
Justice League origin story is a panel
from identity crisis and then there's
this panel of the flash dying during
crisis on Infinite Earths I've actually
used this a lot in some of the flash
videos that I've done for the TV show so
there's all these historical events from
really big moments that they bring back
into continuity and then Batman comes
face to face with his father and it's
like oh my god the look on Flash's face
here is so priceless I love this so let
me know what you guys think about all
this this is just part two the story is
going to continue it's part of the big
button saga in the revelation about dr.
Manhattan so there's still a whole bunch
of stuff that they have to reveal a
whole bunch of other characters from the
golden to Silver Age in the modern age
that they'll bring back into continuity
so I know it sounds kind of complicated
but just let me know in the comments
what kind of comic book bonus videos you
guys want me to do for stuff like this I
totally love doing comic book stuff
every once in a while but I understand
that mostly you just want movie TV
videos so I try to do a balance of both
but congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Joseph Rucka please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
till you can click here to watch that
blast Avatar trailer and you can click
here for this week's arrow and more Teen
Titans thank you so much for watching
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight